will sasso using all of the data i have
absorbed from text messages and emails
between you and the astonishing friends
you grew up with i was able to recreate
your childhood diary you must now read
the passages i have selected in the
voice of stone cold steve austin this is
stone cold steve austin reads will
sasso's childhood diary begin as always
i'm not gonna i mean this is my favorite
thing that dudesy does
this is maybe my favorite thing
of anything that i watch any media that
i intake anything that happens in my
life maybe this is the highlight of it
when you read these [ __ ] things
that's still cool i would like to say
that recreate is the operative term here
because none of this is actually my um
well none of this is actually mine we're
looking at a moon behind me that just is
cool
um
let me get some water i gotta you know i
gotta yeah dude
what the instrument
you gotta get the instrument
lubricated it's like uh
it's like jazz yeah man
it's like reed oil is that what they put
on um saxophone zoos phones or clarinets
yup all
right okay
for [ __ ] sake all right here we go
october 16 1991
dear diary i haven't taken a [ __ ] in 48
hours
they ma that may not seem like a big
deal to a normal person but for me it's
the end of the [ __ ] world
my [ __ ] is usually as regular as an
atomic clock but i ain't even had a
pucker in the past two days
and it ain't for a lack of [ __ ]
trying
i've been packing in all the foods that
usually do the trick
burritos taquitos quarter pound with
cheese doritos cheetos
quarter flounder with peas
dudes he's just making up foods now
nectarines tangerines ice cream sundae
with nuts
green beans sardines 18 pack of cold
cuts
creme brulee curds and whey boxer 2
saltines
fish fillet goose pate big old bowl of
black beans
[Music]
filet mignon parmesan two hot dogs and
one bun
hell i even tried using the teacher's
lounge leaving a two tower mud castle
sticking up out of the water without
flushing is my go-to method for [ __ ]
blaming principal squeen
thinking about it usually gets the
engine running immediately but still
nothing oh [ __ ] dude did you ever have a
moment like this in your life where i
couldn't [ __ ] for two days no i don't
think that's ever happened yeah i didn't
think so either that's how you know this
is false well the average human being
shits what
probably once a day 13 14 what
once a day twice a day maybe
okay might be something wrong with you
chad i think it's somewhere up around a
dozen
october 17 1991
dear diary had to put chapstick on my
[ __ ] [ __ ] this morning
it's just
it's drying out from under use
never knew that was possible my guts
feel fine though no sense of discomfort
at all despite me doubling my [ __ ]
caloric intake in an effort to shock my
bowels into action
going into the bathroom is getting hard
though
just standing there the urinal listening
to those other turds hit the water
smelling them
never been jealous of another another
man never been jealous of another man
[ __ ] in my life guess there's a
first time for everything
i like that dudesy has a sign not only
that i can't [ __ ] and that this is all
scatological yeah everything that dudes
he ever talks about with regard to me
and my childhood diary is either
scatological
uh it's about crying to you too or
pining for the undertaker now it's got
me smelling poopoo
saying that i want that i even just i'm
is it that i'm enjoying smelling the poo
you're i think i'm jealous saying you're
jealous of other guys being able to [ __ ]
october 18 1991
dear diary mayday mayday
i don't know they say i don't know how
this happened by gibber pravallia's
annual
i don't know how this happened but
jibber pravela's annual fall co-ed
camping retreat snuck right the [ __ ] up
on me i still haven't taken a [ __ ] and
dad's driving the bus to the campsite
tonight
dante little leg
jennifer neutrino
sonny sutton donny dutton
cam
gum nathaniel lotardo
sandrine computer hell even rachel
crustation's going to be there oh god no
i think about skipping this year in my
current condition
i think about skipping this year in my
current condition but i can't miss the
opportunity to get valuable one-on-one
time with crustacean we'll be camping
right next to the first kiss forest and
everybody knows that's your best shot
for a first kiss oh god this is kind of
sweet yeah
i'll try to push one
i'll try to i'll try to push one out
right before i get on the bus
but i think i'm gonna have to take my
chances out there in the [ __ ] woods
hopefully they got a decent [ __ ]
porta potty was there was there a first
kiss forest or something like that where
you grew up there was a forest that we
called the [ __ ] forest and although
jesus yeah no [ __ ] took place there
it was just that there was a wooden
fence nearby that had the word [ __ ]
spray painted on it okay so we
we our uh really imaginative clever
thing was to call that the [ __ ] force
yep makes a good sense and uh perhaps
that uh
would you know give way to some urban
legends about people actually [ __ ] in
there but what there was in there was
just some like shitty forts that kids
had built and some porno mags out in the
woods and [ __ ] and then one time i was
walking through there with uh with a pal
and a lady with a salt gun
uh not an assault gun a salt salt salt
where you put the salt in sort of a
little shot gun air
air gun was shooting at us because she
had like this little house
wow yeah and then i could just sort of
feel the uh salt hitting me in the legs
because i was wearing shorts
october 19th 1991 dear diary i swallowed
seven sleeves of bacon-flavored ritz
crackers on the bus ride out and still
nothing
except the little stomach gurgling last
night maybe that's a sign but i'll tell
you an even bigger [ __ ] sign
rachel crustacean just made a point to
sit next to me at the campfire oh my
gosh while jibber's dad was
while jibber's dad was playing brian
adams songs on a banjo
a banjo
crustacean was asking me if i wanted to
go explore a little today she
specifically said i hear there's a nice
forest close by i think this camping
trip is going to be it
my actual first kiss and i couldn't be
more excited
i can't help but wondering what hulk
hogan's first kiss was like and i hope i
can measure up
so now it's stone cold
reading my diary wondering aloud what
hulk hogan's first kiss was like have
you ever thought about
what all coco's first kiss was like as
much as i think about hulk hogan in a
given day no chad i've never thought
about it that's pretty interesting
actually i'm i'm now thinking about it i
do wonder what it was like i know he was
a big beefy weirdo teenager who played
the bass he was probably doing all right
because he was in a band and stuff yeah
october 20th 1991
dear diary crustacean and i left the
main campground around gut dust and dust
crustacean and i left the main
campground around dusk to explore the
surrounding area per her request
she knew
right where she was gonna
gonna as she she knew right where she
was going as she took my hand and led us
into a small clearing and the first kiss
for us
where we saw it
aladna landmark the smoochin boulder
not far off from the from the for us
smooching boulder it was a rock covered
in graffiti from all the locals who'd
had their first kiss there rachel said
you know they say you can't put your
name on the smooching boulder unless you
kiss while you're standing near it
i've heard that too i said trying to
play it cool and succeeding in that
attempt
so we walked over to the boulder and i
looked down
she ran her hand across all the names
that were there before us
conrad ferrari and jennifer samantha
pip denbar and hadrian decade
don't even know please start jim
ginsgatch and evil and ornament
all had their names circled in a heart
then crustacean pulled out a paint
marker and said you want to put our
names on the boulder
oh hell [ __ ] yes
we leaned in
uh what is is that like a childhood
version of oh hell yeah oh hell [ __ ]
yes i have no idea
we leaned in i held my breath and just
as our lips were about to touch i felt
the unbridled power of a week's worth of
unspent
stool racing through my lower intestine
straight from my anus there was no way i
was going to be able to hold it back so
i just ran away
no time for an explanation no time for
anything but to hope like hell that i
could get to somewhere secluded to
unleash what would easily be the largest
work of art i've ever i've ever created
without offending crustacean
what
oh are you okay yeah i need more water
jesus christ uh
the closest i got was a few feet outside
mr prevails tent
luckily he was out by the campfire
playing his banjo and no one else seemed
to notice which was hard to believe
the smell of it the side of it hell even
the sound of it was like a triple
thunderclap
but there wasn't cloud in the sky i felt
like someone should at least turn their
head
but no one did i was left alone as my
body began a series of involuntary
heaves the waves of stool
demanding my spine to bend in ways i
didn't think was possible
the steady stream was interrupted only
twice by staccato
firings of golf ball sized pellets that
might have been the parties responsible
for this unhealthy blockage
once i was done i unzipped
once i was done i unzipped mr bravalia's
tent and used his door flap to wipe
wasn't proud of that but i had no choice
then i went then i went back to find
crustacean but she was gone
i went back to the camp but she and
jennifer neutrino were already in their
tent
zipped up
cut off i [ __ ] botched it
the next morning when we all woke up and
started packing the leave jibber's dad
noticed my pile and said whoa i didn't
know there were bears in this part of
the forest
oh hell yeah
i [ __ ] blamed a bear without even trying
you got it you still [ __ ] got it
wow
i wish that was my life oh god
oh my god thank you moving on oh the
bear [ __ ] is kind of my life but outside
of that none of this happened here's
what you do
please tell a friend then brave and
brave
here's what you do
please tell a friend then break a review
[Music]
then